cuéntanos Cuál es el balance y las
cifras que se conocen tras un mes de
apertura
bueno Muchas gracias Andrés y a toda la
audiencia de ustedes en el sentido de
esta apertura después de siete años
probablemente Pues el paso ha sido
se ha venido llevando de manera ordenada
progresiva después de un cierre
este de más de 7 años de donde los
últimos tres años fueron de rompimiento
de las relaciones este consulares y
entre los países como tal formalmente
entonces van 80 gandolas aproximadamente
con los datos que tú estás manejando en
más de dos millones de dólares
aproximadamente unas 1600 toneladas
métricas
se atreve de Colombia para Venezuela
tela de Blue Jean materiales médicos
como bombonas de oxígeno materiales para
la construcción y Venezuela pues ha
estado enviando también en esto material
sobre todo de carácter siderúrgico
bobinas de acero
meter el ferroso
envases para de vidrio y material de
vidrio también para Colombia eso más o
menos lo que ha venido ocurriendo en
este en este último 30 días las cuales
Pues nosotros estamos celebramos porque
esto se esté dando de la manera como se
ha